Or 3rd
jump.Based on their achievements so far, we
will appoint the two of them as the new leader of the group
.
At the top,
I can't cry
from now on I'm also day I trust
you guys No matter what kind of down you put on the book
[music]
Regardless of position, origin or social status
Just like my husband did to me, that's
good
.  Ushikuro is
also a certain gyudon. It
's perfect for a certain black gyudan-
kun.
Bringing a shining dawn to the world
I'll do it for that purpose
Even if it's like darkness, Hinohikari is deceiving I
'll show you that it will definitely open someday That's a bit too smelly That's
nice too I'm expecting
you from today  I'm the leader of the Golden Dawn,
congratulations on entering William.